[音楽]
あさんこんにちは西森です
まず皆さんに最初にお伺いしたいことがあります
今自分が頑張っていると思う方はどれくらいいらっしゃるでしょうか
手をあげてみてください
ありがとうございます
それでは質問を変えてみます
自分で自分を認められていると思う方はどれくらいいらっしゃるでしょうか
ありがとうございます
今日私が皆さんにお伝えしたいことはただ一つ自分で自分を認めよう
これだけです
では何故この話をしに来たのか
それは自分で自分を認めることが自分が幸せになるための一番の基盤になる
そう私は信じているからです
では自分で自分を認めるためには何が必要なのか
私はこの3つだと思っています
一つが community もう一つ書付き
そして三つ目が問いかけです
私は皆さんの前に今てレックスのスピーカーとしてさあも自信があるかのように立って
いるように見えるかもしれません
でも晶石の話をすると私は昔まで自分に自信を持てない
そんな人間でした
私が中学生の時の話にさかのぼります
その頃私の大切な友人の一人が学校に通えなくなってしまいました
そんな友達に私ができたことは友達として大丈夫
原きっとお声をかけることだけ
そんな自分がすごく不甲斐なく感じていました
そして自分が大学生になったら
心理学を勉強してまた勉強だけではなくてさまざまなことに取り組んで学んでもし隣の
人が困っていたりするときにどんな問題でも助けられる
そんな自分になりたいと思っていました
大学に入ってからは自分が興味を持ったものには何でもどんどんチャレンジしていき
ました
例えばこの写真にあるようにたくさんの子供たちと一緒に
勉強を教えたり遊んだりそれに対する計画を立てるような
ボランティアのサークル人靴も所属しました
また東京に2時間かけてアルバイトに行ったり
また学生にソーシャルビジネスを就職の選択肢にして欲しいと思って団体を立ち上げ
その活動がウェブメディアや新聞に取り上げられたこともありました
やりたい事を思う存分やっているからそれで私は満足なはずでした
でも
例えば東京から帰ってくる夜遅い電車の中で
また一人になった部屋の中でスイッチが系たように落ち込んでしまう時がありました
そんな時に私の心に流れてくる言葉は
あの人はもっと頑張っているのねー
もっともっと頑張らなくちゃもっとできるようにならなくちゃ
そんな今思い返すと辛くなるような言葉でした
もちろんその時の私も辛いと思っていました
でもその理由を自分は努力不足だからがんばっていないからというふうに思っていまし
た
また自分の努力が実る時もたくさんありましたがそんな時も今はいいけど次はもっと
できるようにさらに努力を重ねなくてはというプレッシャーを自分に課していました
そんな時あるひとつの衝撃的な質問が私になりかけられたのです
それが先ほど皆さんに冒頭でお伺いした
自分で自分を認められているのという質問です
その質問がなりかけられたのは昨年の夏
シアトルで行われたプログラムに参加した時でした
そのプログラムはソーシャルイノベーションやリーダーシップについて
日本全国から集まった25人の若者と一緒に
例えばソーシャルビジネスを行っている企業に訪問したりまた対話や議論やチームでの
プロジェクトを通して自分自身やリーダーシップ
またそう処理の
べーションについて学ぶそんなプログラムでした
私はその中で自分と向き合う方法を学んだり
さまざまな人がいる中でどうリーダーシップを発揮していけばいいのか
またソーシャルイノベーションについて学べる平気な時間を過ごしました
そして自分が一歩ずつ自分を受け入れて成長している
そんな感覚を得ていました
でも帰国が迫ったある日ふとこんなことを思いました
また日本に戻ったら毎日いろいろなことが忙しく過ぎて行ってまた自分でうまいこと
自分を認められなくなってしまうのではないか
そんなとき先ほどのあなたは自分で自分を認められているのという質問をその
プログラムのオーガナイザーから追いかけられたわけです
その質問された時
私ははいという言葉が全く喉から出てきませんでした
そしてその応えられない自分というのを目の当たりにしたときに初めてあああ
私は自分で自分を認められていないんだということに気づきました
それは今まで自分の中で無意識に蓋をしていただ
そんなことに向き合えた瞬間でした
でもその後すぐに今まで自分で自分を認められていなかった私が明日からすぐに自分に
自信を持つことなんてできない
そんな風に思いました
でもオーガナイザーはこう言ってくれました
大丈夫あなたは自分で自分を認めることができる
そして
他の人と比較して自分を評価するのではなく自分が頑張ったという気持ちを大切に
自分自身を褒めてあげてというふうに言ってくれました
シアトルから日本に帰ってきて
私が行うようになったことがあります
それはこの画面に出ている女も毎日見ること
書いてあるのは
speak エロー3
ティリス tr スパイスを3
日本語にすると自分を褒めをそして他の人からもらった賞賛を素直に受け取ろうという
言葉です
これはシアトルから帰ってくる直前に自分でメモに書いて
そして毎日毎日朝見返していました
いわば自分にとっての近いです
そして毎日このメモを見て自分を褒めたり
称賛したりということを習慣化するようになってからは報道に変化が起きました
例えば今まで集団の中で意見を言う時
それまでの私であればこんなこと言ったらバカにされるかもしれない
こんなこと考えている人はいないかもしれないと言ってなかなか発言できなかったりし
ましたが
自分の意見というのは他の人にはないオリジナルなもので
そしてこの意見をこの場で言うことで新たな示唆を他の人に提供できる
そうもうとそんなのに意見が言いやすくなりました
また例えば他の人から西森さんはこんな活動をしているんだ
面白いね頑張ってるねというふうに声をかけられたとき
以前であればいやそんなことはないだって私これもできないしこれもできないしあの人
はもっと頑張っている子というふうに自然に自分を否定していたのですがそういった
自分を卑下する言葉というのは自然に薄れていき
逆に今の自分に何をプラスしていこうか
そして他の人に今の自分が与えられ
ているものはないかという発想に変わっていきました
ん
ここで私のストーリーは終わりですが次は皆さんのストーリーをつくっていく番です
そのために自分で自分を認めるための3つの端を最後に紹介したいと思います
まず一つ目が community
例えば皆さんが
何か集団の中で自分の意見を述べるという時にもしかしたら以前の私のようにこんな
こと言ったらバカにされるかもとか
こんなことよない方がいいかもしれないと思うことがあるかもしれません
でも例えば皆さんのいるコミュニティが一人一人が違うということを前提にその違いと
いうものを楽しみ
強みとして受け入れるようなコミュニティであればどうでしょうか
きっと皆さんは自分の意見を素直に安くなると思いますし
今まで自分が他の人よりも劣っていると思っていたところはもしかしたら他の人とは
違う
とても素敵なところだと認められるようになると思います
そして皆そういったコミュニティをみなさんのまわりにもきっとあると思いますし
皆さんの手で作っていくこともできます
そのコミュニティがわたしにとってはシアトルデータ仲間たちでした
そしてそんなコミュニティの中に入ると皆さんもある日自分が自分を認められていない
ということに気づくかもしれません
もしかしたらそれは皆さんに撮って少し辛いことかもしれません
でも自分の正しい自己認識を知るということはみなさんがそこから先に一歩進む上で
とても大切な重要な一歩であると小沢氏はシアトルでの経験から感じています
そして気づき自分が自分を認められていないということに気付いた後はこの問いかけが
重要になってきます
自分を認められないのは他の人基準や自分はこうあるべきだというものに囚われている
からです
でもずっとそうやって私はこうあらねばならないとかこういう風にならなくちゃいけ
ないと思い込んでいたらなかなか前進することは難しいと思います
大切なのは今自分は他の人の基準で考えているのか
自己基準で考えているのかおとうことです
他の人の基準で考えている場合には例えば昨日の自分と比べて今日自分よりもできる
ようになったことや変わったことに目を向けてください
そうやって他人の基準から自分の基準に引き戻すことができれば自分の成長をちょっと
ずつ実感することができるようになるはずです
そして皆さんがこの123おけ順を得て自分を認めることができるようになったら
そこからは皆さんが一つ目のコミュニティをつくる番です
皆が安心安全の場でいられるようなコミュニティをつくってそこに前の人を巻き込むの
もいいと思います
そうやってコミュニティの中で発言できる人を増やしていくということは私もシアトル
から帰ってこのエスビーラボを作ったり
またハミトークという団体で一人一人が本当はここの中でやりたいと思っていることや
言いたいと思っていることを主張できたり
実現できたりするような場
作りを行ってみました
きっとこのような場づくりは皆さんにもできると思います
そして他の人から刺激をもらったり他の人に認めてもらうよりもまずは自分で自分を
認めること
これが皆さんが幸せになるための最初の一歩になると思いますし私はここにいる皆さん
は必ず自分で自分を認めることができるそういうふうに信じています
以上ですありがとうございました
[拍手]